>> Geraldo: I DON'T LIKE TO
KICK A GUY WHEN HE IS DOWN BUT
THIS IS A LOATHSOME CREATURE.
MICHAEL AVENATTI HEADING TO
PRISON AND THE DISGRACED LAWYER
WILL SPEND TWO AND A HALF YEARS
BEHIND BARS FOR TRYING TO EXTORT
NIKE FOR $25 MILLION.
HE WAS FOUND WEEPING IN THE
COURTROOM TODAY AND HIS LEGAL
TROUBLES FAR FROM OVER.
HE FACES TWO MORE TRAILS ON THE
WEST COAST.
THE MEDIA LOOKING FOOLISH AFTER
PRAISING THIS CREEP.
>> TO ME, YOU ARE LIKE THE
HOLY SPIRIT.
ALL PLACES COME ALL TIMES.
>> LOOKING AT 2020, THE ONLY
REASON I'M TAKING THIS SERIOUS
AS A CONTENDER BECAUSE OF THE
PRESENCE ON CABLE NEWS.
I READ ABOUT THIS, YOU ARE
CURRENTLY LEADING THE PACK AMONG
2020 CONTENDERS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE APPEAR >> WILL
COME I THINK YOU ARE DOING A
HELL OF A JOB.
I DON'T THINK YOU ARE DOING THIS
FOR THE MONEY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Geraldo: SO DANA, IS THIS
AFFECTION THEY SHOWED
MICHAEL AVENATTI THAT QUALITIES
OR JUST ABOUT --
>> Dana: GETTING CARRIED AWAY
WITH THEMSELVES IN THE HOPES
THAT MAYBE SOMEBODY WILL BE ABLE
TO TAKE ON DONALD TRUMP AT THE
TIME AND MICHAEL AVENATTI HE
PRAISED THE MEDIA ATTENTION AND
ALWAYS AVAILABLE.
IN THE THING IS HE WAS QUITE
BEHIND THE TIMES.
WHAT DO YOU DO NOW IF YOU WANT
TO GET $25 MILLION FROM A
COMPANY IS YOU BASICALLY GO
UNDERGROUND AND ASK THEM FOR
$50 MILLION IN CRYPTO.
THAT IS HOW YOU GET PAID.
HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT HE'S
DOING IN A MORE.
>> Greg: YOU BECOME A
DIVERSITY CONSULTANT.
YOU WOKE UP BY THE CORPORATION.
>> Dana: YOU COULD DO THAT AS
WELL.
I'M GLAD JUSTICE WAS DONE AND
NIKE'S LAWYER SNIFFED THIS OUT
IMMEDIATELY AND CONTACTED THE
FBI.
>> Geraldo: THE GUY IS DRIVING
FOR ARIS WITH $2,000 SUITS AND
WHERE'S THE MONEY COMING FROM?
AND THE STORIES, DANIELS,
STORMY DANIELS.
>> Greg: I LIKE HOW YOU FORGET
HER NAME.
HOW DO YOU FORGET HER?
ONE MONTH FOR EVERY HAIR ON HIS
HEAD.
WILL ZUCKER VISIT HIM IN JAIL?
AFTER ALL...
>> Dana: JESSE WATTERS!
>> Jesse: I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
WRONG WITH THAT.
>> Greg: HOW DOES CNN REPORT
THIS?
MICHAEL AVENATTI THEY'LL LOWER
YOUR WE HEARD ABOUT TODAY WE DID
NOT PARTY WITH HIM AND NO
PICTURES WITH DON LEMON IN
HAMPTON BUT JUST WENT TO JAIL
AND WE ARE SO HAPPY HE WENT TO
JAIL.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH HIM.
>> THEY PUSHED THIS GUY ON
AMERICA AND YOUR QUESTION TO
DANA, THEY WERE DELUDED BY,
DELUSIONAL LOATHING OF
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS GUY WAS A MASS MURDER, THEY
STILL -- IT IS CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
THAT, JESSIE.
>> Geraldo: YOU CAN SPEAK
ABOUT MEDIA BIAS AND ALL THE
REST OF IT BUT YOU SEE IT LAID
THEY'RE HERE IS A GUY EMBRACED
IN A WAY THAT WAS REALLY OBSCENE
AND SO GUSHY.
MICHAEL AVENATTI,
MICHAEL AVENATTI AND IT TURNS
OUT HE IS JUST A LOW LIFE.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE STREET
SMARTS.
THIS TABLE HAS STREET SMARTS.
WE COULD SMELL HIS CHEAP COLOGNE
FROM A MILE AWAY.
WE SAW IT COMING.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE STREET
SMARTS OVER IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HALLWAYS.
THEY GET DUPED.
REMEMBER JOSIE SMALL IT?
I'M HUNGRY FOR A SUBWAY SANDWICH
AND IT IS 40 BELOW, COME ON, MAN
AND THEY BELIEVE THE GUY A WEEK
LATER AND THIS GUY COME A LITTLE
SHADY, LEGAL MANEUVERS WITH
PULLING VICTIMS OUT OF HIS HAT
TO DESTROY BRETT KAVANAUGH
SUCKING UP TO EVERYBODY WITH
GETTING SUCKERED WITH THIS GUY.
HITCHED A WAGON TO CRIMINAL
CARNIVAL BARKER BECAUSE THEY
LOATHED TRUMP.
THEY THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE THE
SILVER BULLET.
WHAT I NOTICED THAT THE GUY
ALMOST ON TV AS MUCH AS FAUCI.
WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE ON TV AS
MUCH AS FAUCI AND MICHAEL OF AN
ODDITY.
THERE IS A BIG CRASH.
>> Greg: ALMOST AS MUCH AS
SELLING A BOOK.
>> Dagen: I'M NOT CARRYING
ABOUT STORMY DANIELS BUT THIS
GUY IS GOING TO JAIL.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY CAN'T SMELL
OUT THIS?
GUY?
THEY CAN'T SNIFF HIM OUT BECAUSE
THEY ARE HIM, THE COMBINATION,
YES, GIFT WEIGHTED AND ARROGANT.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THIS IDIOT
GOES TO NIKE LIKE "I'M GOING T